[Applause]
my name is dr david michael smith and
i'm a member of the houston united front
against fascism
[Music]
the anti-fascist movement is pretty
diverse a lot of attention has been paid
to some of the younger folks that dress
in black and you know often are
anarchists or anarcho-socialists houston
united front against fascism
has a little bit different approach
some of us have come from communist and
socialist backgrounds others are just
genuinely progressive folks on the left
but we do like working with everybody
including the so-called antifa black
bloc in fighting against fascism and
trumpsterism our organization was formed
to oppose
the trump movement neo-nazis other
fascists that have taken to the streets
of greater houston over the last several
years so we sponsor militant but
non-violent protest we educate people
about the threat posed by the far right
and we're glad to have played a role in
the defeat of trump nationally we're
contributing here in houston but also
nationally to the spike in homicides and
that's what i would call a growing
legitimacy of our police agencies in the
united states in the wake of the murder
of george floyd you've had massive
massive protests more than 15 million
people protest in the summer of 2020 and
even though they did not produce a lot
of police reforms it has had an effect
in the communities across this country a
lot of young people who might be
inclined to commit potentially violent
crimes are now asking well if the cops
don't have to obey the law why should i
and this is a huge huge problem
everybody agrees that violent crime is a
problem there's no disagreement about
that but our elected officials and
politicians need to hear from the
community that not all of us want more
cops or harsher policing we need to get
at the root causes of the problem we
need to tackle poverty racism economic
inequality and all the rest so look i'm
not an anarchist i'm a communist i
definitely believe in having law
enforcement in whatever kind of society
you want but you've got to have law
enforcement that's answerable and
accountable to the communities we need
democratic community control of the
police in our country our country not
just houston has always had a huge
homicide problem social scientists all
know that we have the most
violent kind of society the highest
homicide rate of any of the advanced
capitalist countries and it has gotten
worse in the last two years
if you look at statistics from the
centers for disease control a department
of justice in washington
we know that the hike and uh or spike in
homicides has occurred in part because
of covet you know kobe's had a lot of
really bad effects on people
psychologically financially and so forth
so that's part of it you know another
part in houston that's peculiar to
houston is that we have a terribly
backlash backlogged court problem you
know basically we had hurricane harvey
in 2017 and then covet over the last
couple years and that combination has
led to check this out about 100 000
cases that have not been heard yet and
some of which involve people who are
still out on the street and able to
commit crimes again so i think that when
you look at you know covet and houston
the backlog of court cases and this
legitimation crisis for the police i
think those explain the most recent
spikes